[Applaudissements]
on était bien on était tous les deux
isabelle morini bosc est ce qu'elle est
arrivée isabel isabella à regarder ça y
est isabelle attané attendez attendez
attendez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais regardez il fait plus 250 kg ou là
où ça attention qu'est ce qu'il fait est
ce qu'ils peuvent danser tous les deux
perdent donc saint géry presque y penser
avec lourd et qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça
marche était patron pas trompés de garde
comme isabelle commence à me faire peur
c'est la nappe après l a pas fait
attention à la passion ascension allez
un dernier petit chama les abeilles la
dernière touche un ballon à ses débuts
elle était vraiment à n a pas peur du
tout franchement d'isabelle un dernier
petit saint malo mais franchement c'est
pas comment une crise amène
[Applaudissements]
moi